A pilot on an early
morning flight over
eastern France captures
this image.
It looks like a city at
night with all of the
street lights
illuminating all the
roads and houses.
Closer examination of the
image reveals something
strange.
You can see rows of
flames that have erupted
all the way across this
vast area in France.
But why?
The aerial image has
captured a strange
technique the farmers
employ to save their
livelihoods from ruin.
Farmers lined their
fields with torches and
then light them so that
these little fires.
Right next to the grapes
are able to warm up the
air right around the
grapes and prevent the
frost.
But it's actually not the
heat of the torches
themselves. That's the
primary factor to keeping
the crops safe.
It's the smoke that's
the critical thing.
The smoke acts like
almost a layer of clouds,
like a fog that traps
the heat of the earth
from getting out into
space.